Dr. Jack Bright’s life has been largely
defined by one really bad day.
Namely, back when he was a mere junior researcher
from an illustrious, complicated, and Foundation-connected
family, he was given the task of carrying
the SCP-963 medallion all the way from the
test chamber back to its containment area.
Simple enough, seeing as - other than being
indestructible - the medallion had no obvious
anomalous effects.
That was, until Able breached containment
nearby, and hacked the young Jack Bright to
death with his anomalous blades.
But, in what you could either describe as
a miracle or a terrible, terrible curse, Dr.
Bright wasn’t dead - His soul was trapped
in the medallion, taking over any body it
touched.
This has given Dr. Bright a form of body-swapping
immortality, which has made him both a valuable
asset to the goals of the SCP Foundation and
also an extremely unhappy man.
But what would you do if you were immortal
like Jack Bright?
We posed this very question in our community
posts section, and now, we’re going to see
what the fans of SCP Explained would do with
the poisoned gift of true immortality.
The unknown avenger said, “I would become
a vigilante who doesn’t have to worry about
facing justice through the death sentence.
If I get executed I’ll simply reincarnate
as someone new and continue my vigilante justice
work.”
Well, that’s somewhat terrifying, thank
you for sharing, unknown avenger.
All we ask is that you politely keep your
dangerous vigilante activities away from us,
just so we don’t get caught in the crossfire.
We’re really not sure the universe can take
two Deadpools…
Vance Alexander said, “Bearing in mind the
duplicating ability of the medallion, I'd
make two of myself and then fight myself.
Or I wouldn't limit it to two, I'd make a
whole bunch of copies and have a battle royale
of myself.
May the best copy win!”
This gives us an important opportunity to
remind you of one of Dr. Bright’s lesser-known
abilities: Contact with the necklace means
immediate brain death, and if the necklace
is removed from a wearer, the body will simply
collapse and die.
However, if the necklace is left on the body
for thirty days, a copy of Dr. Bright’s
consciousness will remain even when the necklace
is removed.
Theoretically, this could be used to create
a clone army.
And using that army for self-against-self
gladiator battles would undeniably be pretty
kickass.
DeadlyVeggie said, “If I was immortal, I
would try to play and complete the stories
of every D&D character I have made.
Now THAT would be something only an immortal
could do.”
A truly avant-garde approach: Using one infinite
life to live the countless finite lives of
others, knowing not even a Nat 20 will save
you from your own purgatorial existence.
Phantom said, “That's actually a really
tough one...
I'm unironically scared to death of dying,
so I guess I'd just try to do the things I
want to do?
Probably would end up trying to become a well-known
gamer or something lol, or maybe teach forever.
It's depressing, since it's such a curse to
be immortal.”
While we do think being a teacher or a well-known
gamer are both noble pursuits for the immortal-about-town,
we’re honestly more curious as to what being
ironically scared of dying would be.
Is that what the kids are into nowadays?
Let us know down in the comments.
Mr. Knight The Detective said, “I would
have time to watch pretty much every cartoon,
anime, movie, and series I ever missed.
After I'm done with all of them I will fulfill
my bucket list with other wishes.”
This is certainly a novel way to use total
immortality.
But a word to the wise: Make sure you get
through your watch list before the rest of
humanity is wiped out by whatever XK-Class
End of the World Scenario lady luck has lined
up for us - our money is either on climate
change or the duplicating cakes - because
if you’re the only one left and you happen
to break your glasses, you’ll be forever
wandering around the empty wastes, tearfully
murmuring, “It isn’t fair.
There was time now.
There was time…”
Whatisamelon said, “Personally, I would
try and make a time machine to watch many
historical events unfold.
I mean you have plenty of time and you can’t
die from any certain event.
It could be fun.”
A lofty goal indeed.
Here’s a fun exercise for you, to immediately
find out if ever you’re going to create
or at least obtain time travel technology
in your lifetime: Make a promise to yourself
that if you do, you’ll come back to this
exact moment.
Okay.
Good.
However, if a version of you from the future
hasn’t just appeared in front of you, then
I’m afraid I have some very disappointing
news for you on the whole time travel thing…
Cade Peterson said, “I am kinda confused
with how the amulet works.
If dr bright died, and then somebody put the
amulet on an animal, would he become the animal,
and still be able to talk, or would the animal
just turn in to him.
Next question with that in mind, couldnt he
just get it to be put on an anomolous object,
such as 682, and use it for good?”
All very valid questions that is worth answering
before we move on.
First, if Dr. Bright’s 963 amulet was placed
on the body of an animal, it would merely
plant his consciousness into the animal - not
in any way physically transform the beast.
Whether the animal could talk purely depends
on whether it has the necessary anatomy to
imitate human-esque speech patterns.
And as to your second question, this has been
attempted, with SCP-682 specifically, in fact
- see our previous video on how that epic
battle played out.
But to give you an abridged version, some
anomalous entities are more resistant to SCP-963’s
abilities than us mere humans are.
Not all potential hosts are created equal.
FoxyGamer said, “I’d drink one drop of
water from every country and one drop of lava
from every volcano then probably watch as
every generation of humanity expand and rule
it.”
This is the exact kind of bizarre, inexplicable
madness we were hoping to see when we first
posted this question.
The specificity of these suggestions implies
a fascinating level of planning and foresight.
And it’s undeniable that if you were able
to prove to people you had imbibed a drop
of lava from every single volcano on earth
- there’s about 1350 active ones, by the
way - you probably would have some claim to
being humanity’s supreme ruler.
Mangolad said, “If I had the power like
Bright, I would create the ultimate wine - make
it rest on a barrel as long as possible.”
Ah, yes, I see we have a person of culture
among us.
Can’t wait for all the comments to be about
me saying “Among Us.”
Nonetheless, having Dr. Bright’s immortality
would be an excellent excuse to cultivate
some of the finest aged wine the world has
ever known.
Perhaps those sweet overtones and nutty undertones
will dull the existential horror of never
knowing the eternal rest of death…
Quote C said, “Oh boy!
Immortality!
Now I can dedicate more time to my favorite
hobby!
Procrastinating on animation projects!”
That’s the can-do attitude we love here
at SCP Explained!
Eternity certainly lasts a while, imagine
all the incredible animations you could not
get done in that time!
Inspirational!
_theoutsider_ said, “Dedicating yourself
to something meaningful like Jack Bright is
the only way to do it.
That is, of course, after you had some fun
for the first few decades.”
We couldn’t agree more, outsider.
After all, “You Only Live Once” still
applies, even if that Once lasts forever.
Dr. Bright tried to have some fun of his own
before he leveled out, and now there’s a
very long list of things he’s not allowed
to do.
Perhaps we should cover that someday…
Michael Awesome said, “If I were immortal,
I would steer humanity into the direction
of logic and science, guiding them from the
shadows into an eternal golden age using the
resources I have accumulated through forever.”
That certainly sounds Awesome, Michael.
However, feel free to call us pessimists,
but humanity has never been that easy to steer
out of the shadows.
See: The long list of very smart, paradigm-shifting
individuals executed as witches or heretics
for such bold and radical claims as “the
earth rotates around the sun” and “math
exists.”
But we’ll be happy to be proven wrong on
this front, of course.
Silent Monke said, “Dedicate my life into
turning into a hotdog sandwich.”
Hey, if you can find a very unscrupulous man
with a meat-mincing machine, you may take
a lot less time than eternity to see this
peculiar dream become a glorious reality.
Noweq 69 - nice - said, “I would make an
army of myself and when i wouldn't want to
go the store then i would just send my clone
for some doritos.”
There are a lot of truly nefarious and megalomaniacal
things you can do with an army of like-minded
clones - like the battle royale guy from earlier
- so it’s relieving that you’d just use
yours for performing menial tasks.
But bear in mind, just because these clones
are like-minded doesn’t mean they’ll be
subservient to you.
If you’re the controlling type, you might
even have a violent clone uprising on your
hands, and trust us, nobody likes an Attack
of the Clones.
Food for thought…
Thevoicesgaming said, “Depending on how
the medallion works I’d try to keep me and
the women I love alive if I can’t do that
then I’d give up the medallion to the Scp
foundation (assuming it exists) a life without
someone isn’t a life worth living no matter
how much you’ve accomplished it’ll always
get boring eventually.”
A very poignant point.
We have good and bad news.
Technically speaking, with the help of your
963 medallion, your loved one’s body can
survive.
However, their brain will technically be occupied
by a copy of your own consciousness.
But if that copy is willing to play pretend,
well, maybe you can make some kind of mutually-beneficial
arrangement?
The finer details of that will be something
for you and yourself to sort out.
Good luck.
FoxFilms said, “I would freak someone out
by repeatedly (over the course of a few years)
going up to them in different bodies, and
saying the same phrase each time.”
Using your abilities to gaslight one individual
over the course of several years definitely
seems like something Dr. Bright might do if
he was in a bad mood, so we’re sure he would
appreciate this act of extreme anomalous pettiness.
Just promise you won’t do it to us - This
really isn’t something we want on our plate
right now.
Zero Confidence said, “Well, a good portion
of my lives would be developing a meaningful
relationship with 682 via the process of annoying
them with my presence every few weeks, or
when I’m just tired of my current body and
ready to move on to that nice D-class who
was next in line.”
This is definitely an original one.
We appreciate that you’re still rosy-eyed
about the possibility of a single atom of
goodness residing somewhere deep beneath SCP-682’s
nasty, scaly hide.
Whether you’ll ever actually find it - even
with an eternity of searching - is another
question.
But if Good Will Hunting has taught us anything,
if you repeat “It’s Not Your Fault”
enough, even if it kills you a thousand times
in between, it might eventually have a cathartic
emotional outpouring.
Hey, it’s worth a try, right?
Cracker County said, “I'd enact minuscule
amounts of tomfoolery at the expense of others.”
Hey, you know what you like, and you’re
doing what you can to obtain it.
We can’t help but respect that about you.
Sometimes, setting modest yet attainable goals
is the most efficient way to go, even when
you have eternity at your fingertips.
Nicholas Lau said, “Personally, I'd go into
space with a lot of pain medication and magnetic
boots, then do laps around the asteroid belt.
If I'm immortal, even with all that pain,
I could do a proper jog that isn't just strolling
around the block.
Also, figure out a cure for cancer, and whipping
SCP-038 with really long spaghetti for infinite
food.”
Wow.
This is a hell of a bucket list, even for
someone who knows they’re never actually
going to kick that bucket.
We don’t want to mess with your dreams here,
but it is important to remember that there
is considerable distance between asteroids
in an asteroid belt, even in a low-gravity
environment, so you may need to seriously
work on your jumping skills.
The cure for cancer is an undeniably noble
goal.
And we’re personally very invested in you
using SCP-038 - A tree that clones anything
that touches it - to create infinite spaghetti.
We find that idea to be molto bene.
Minescarfedbro said, “If I was immortal
I would probably go to the cell of "shy guy"
and look at him.”
That is certainly an interesting way to spend
your time, but there are two worrying potential
issues that could come up here.
Famously, SCP-096 leaves no trace of its victims,
so it’d be fascinating to see if the SCP-963
medallion would be left after the onslaught.
However, we find our second concern to be
an even more frightening possibility: What
if the rage state of SCP-096 carried over
between bodies?
What if, every time you regenerated, SCP-096
was activated anew, and made a beeline for
you?
You would be in the worst kind of hell: Caught
in an infinite loop of being murdered by SCP-096
again and again, until the world collapses
between the two of you.
So yes, we personally think that this little
stunt just may not be worth the risk…
Darfordial said, “I would probably spend
my time learning all languages, science, and
basically everything I’d guess, and then
try to ascend high in the ranks of the foundation
and someday become a member of the O5 Council
(unlikely though since the O5 could be immortal
as well) and maybe accumulate more power by
throwing my medallion at anomalies.”
Funnily enough, this is pretty much exactly
how Jack Bright himself uses the medallion,
so you’d probably be in good company with
the SCP Foundation’s grumpiest immortal!
Pandie Goodies said, “I'd probably do whatever
I can to ensure every meme and joke thrown
at the internet revivable.
I'll bring back cat burgers memes in the year
3022.”
Of all of the suggestions we’ve observed
today, this is undeniably the evilest of them
all, Pandie Goodies.
And we swear that if you use this power to
give immortality to the Among Us memes that
plague our comment sections, you will have
made a powerful enemy in SCP Explained today,
you have our word on that.
Samantha Agius said, “To be honest I feel
sorry for Dr. Jack Bright and his family(everyone
deserves a fresh start right?)”
We’re with you on this one, Samantha.
The ballad of Jack Bright himself, and the
terrible tragedies and upsets that pervade
his family, easily tugs at the heartstrings.
If today has taught us anything, it’s that
there truly is no longevity without tragedy.
Horseman Gaming said, “If I was immortal,
I'd spend my time finding ways to become as
smart as Rick Sanchez, invent the interdimensional
portal gun, and start dimension hopping...or,
more accurately, pitching my medallion into
the portal, seeing where it goes.
After all, it is indestructible.”
Using the SCP-963 medallion to become Rick
Sanchez is certainly a new one.
Perhaps then you can place the medallion onto
a pickle, and it’ll be the funniest--
Wait, what do you mean it’s a dead meme?
Well, it doesn’t matter, because if Pandie
Goodies gets their way, no meme will ever
really die, no matter how obnoxious!
Prisimity said, “I would plant as many trees
in the world as I can and watch them grow.”
Well, that’s just incredibly wholesome,
and we think this would be a truly wonderful
way to use the power of immortality.
A shiny SCP Foundation gold star for you,
Prisimity!
UAF Gaming said, “I'd probably actually
start working on my mental health.”
Hey, for what it’s worth, don’t wait for
the gift of immortality to be bestowed on
you before you start working on your mental
health.
Working on yourself is always a good thing,
and if you’ve been looking for an excuse,
there’s no better time to start than right
now.
Leora Sellouk said, “After sulking over
how everyone I know and will know is either
dead or will die during my never-ending lifespan,
I would learn everything I could about any
topic simply because I had the time to, whether
it be about the weather or about anomalies
and the foundation.
I would set to working my way into the foundation
and getting a good acceptable job that gave
me enough clearance to be able to access the
most information possible.
I would then work in two ways, one by helping
with the actual goals of the foundation and
all that comes with that, and also by working
my passion, writing stories, and implementing
the many things I would see working at such
a place as the SCP foundation, different enough
that it wasn’t an exact copy, but similar
enough so that if someone were to read it
after having heard rumors about such a beast,
they would assume it came from the book and
was in fact, fiction and not reality, an extra
defense against people finding out the truth.”
Dr. Bright…
Is that you?
What did we tell you about making sock puppet
accounts and commenting on our community posts?
The O5 Council is going to give you a very
stern talking to about this…
Jhonnyplays said, “I’d play every video
game out there and I’d watch every SCP Explained
- Story & Animation video.”
We think this is a truly excellent idea, and
something we should all do right now, even
if we’re not immortal.
Heck, perhaps you should start with “SCP
Immortal Dr. Bright Explained” and “DR.
BRIGHT FOR PRESIDENT SCP-4444 - Bush v. Gore”,
a great pair of videos if you’re interested
in more exploits from the truly legendary
Dr. Jack Bright!
What?
We’re just saying…